we're in the infant stages right now so
just taking it step by step and it's
exciting but it's certainly not
something i'm taking lightly
we started out in the cessna
it is a single-engine airplane i needed
to build up their spatial awareness
inside the aircraft we got to pretty
much take off ourselves the first time
unreal oh my gosh
then i took them to an extra which is
more of a high performance aircraft that
can pull g's go inverted doing loops
that's amazing oh my god whoa
that is
awesome
flying like that might sound easy but it
was tough
when you're in an aircraft pulling hard
maneuvers it is intense
you're just telling yourself don't pass
out don't pass out
it's crazy
next we took them to the l-39 and they
went and flew aerobatics to feel what
it's like in a jet
we're training on loops we're training
on rolls
it's good wings level get some speed wow
like the first turn it was like two g's
i felt i'm like okay i'm not gonna be
able to do this oh my god oh my god oh
my god at this point we started working
on the formation flying so that they're
used to having other aircraft around us
no
pride of my freaking life
you